au grammy awards qui avait lieu la nuit
dernière à los angeles le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky s'était
exprimée lors d'une allocution
enregistrée le président ukrainien a
demandé une nouvelle fois le soutien à
son pays face à l'envahisseur russe je
vous propose de l'écouter
nous défendre notre liberté de vivre
d'aimer de nous faire entendre sur notre
terre nous combattons la russie porteuse
d'un horrible silence avec ses bombes un
silence de mort
remplissez ce silence avec votre musique
dit la vérité sur la guerre sur vos
réseaux sociaux à la télévision
soutenez-nous de toutes les manières
possibles tout sauf le silence et après
viendra la paix